on this week's show how to generate
infinite returns from property
investments in the news we're going to
discuss and simulate is financially free
challenge and we're gonna be answering
your property related questions hi
almost leads I'm Alistair Cunningham
welcome to this week's property
investors podcast I'm excited for the
show
if you got yes any anything you can tell
us about your personal life this week I
got a new iPhone put on your iPhone 11
lower there's I'm not I'm not using it
yeah I'm selling my old one because this
one keeps freezing
whenever I'm online and stuff at art so
since we put the new update on it keeps
freezing but got a virus or something
yes I'm going to say the evils of horses
theatre show do you know I drove past
the theater that's a holiday and I I've
seen that advertised on Ticketmaster a
lot and I was gonna go and see it as
well oh yeah when he going I'll get on
Monday to it I was gonna take its
premise be and what did he like it I
love that
I thought I thought I thought there's no
way cuz once you've seen this saw the
shawl it's going to be like a bit of a
letdown but you know some of these
theater productions are really good yeah
have you ever been to see the Jersey
Boys no yeah it's really good the Jersey
Boys were a boy like a rock band from
the 70s and 80s you've know the songs
like let's sing one there now could L
know if I know it
so you know the songs wanna sing one
then no just give us just just goes
together to just go for the go for the
to what like a man that's not true I'm
not gonna sing it did anyway right I
came out there I think I do know it
though format I'm sure remember just
draw me of the tune and I'll sing it I
can't remember it lift up my head I'm
having a brain freak mm-hmm master
anyway I went see the theater Sheila it
was freakin amazing amazing I was like I
was like I got dragged along and I was
like okay this is gonna be huge
and just friends with so I got dragged
along and my and I was like this is
gonna be really good really good and
then I know it's gonna be rubbish right
he said it's gonna be really good and I
got there and I was thinking this is
just grim it was boring and then
suddenly they after the first interval
it like just came alive and it was
actually it was bloody amazing it was
really good really good so theatres are
really good get along too Theo's really
what's the best thing about being here
in London is all that is all this
nightlife entertainment books on the
friends Joe the friends trip did the I
was like a parody of friends or
something but his friends the musical of
course I didn't hear do you know that's
what a lot of it London doesn't matter
what time of day or night it is you can
do what you want to do like the other
night I couldn't it was like two o'clock
in the morning couldn't sleep so I went
out I actually went out and played poker
at two o'clock in the morning it sounds
unbelievable how do you generate an
infinite return okay okay now I suppose
in order for it to be infinite version
you can put no money in not necessarily
well oh you've got to pull your money
back out all pull your money back out
okay so that's what we're gonna talk
about buy refurbish finance I put your
money in put it back out yeah and then
therefore even then on it kind of it's
an infinite return yeah so I'm and we're
gonna look at okay so first of all very
quickly in in literally 30 seconds what
is BA refurbishing finance language
drink some water while isn't it okay
this is where you find a property in its
rundown negotiate blue market value
price it could be run there for many
reasons inheritance just dilapidated old
not being refurbished whatever inherited
anything I just I really run them
properly you go into it you add value to
it increases value refinance it is true
is its true market value which you've no
Payne because you've done the work to it
refinance there and pulled pulled your
money out hopefully pulling all of your
money out mm-hmm nice we could put like
like a countdown Joe think I'd be quite
cool yeah okay cool see so that's that's
what it is so I suppose the question
that most people want to do it's just
two things one how did you find a
property like okay and then number two
when you find a property property like
that how do you know that you're gonna
be able to refinance let's do one thing
how do you find them
I'm you want to be looking okay so you
should all have an area a patch that you
work in and first thing is speak to all
the agents in that patch that you know
speak to them all and say look this is
what I'm looking for I'm looking for the
smelliest the dirtiest house you've got
if there's needles on the floor even
better look for the houses that are run
down got kitchens missing all that sort
of stuff just look the Rhonda another
thing is when you go in and say that
like are they kind of like the thing is
most people shy away from all these sort
of deals because they see all and they
think it's just you know who would want
to touch that they just assume that
you're just a smelly dirty human being
that wants to live no because they're
just happy to get rid of these
properties if there are if they've got
problems available that they can't shift
the way I do look like one to the stage
now so Luke what have you got that you
just cannot sell ask them and they live
normally in the drawer got some
paperwork of something that they can't
sale they can't shift they can't get
they can't get by a phone and I've now
gone view them and I'll see what's going
on with them and see how we can best
help them the properties to look for but
like if you're scouring through
Rightmove looking for deals yeah look
for houses I've got the old swirly
old-fashioned carpets that I've got the
old-fashioned gas bonfire and bar gas
fires in the front room
that I've got beige our texts are texts
yeah our text is good chip put a
chipboard wallpaper or chip wherever is
and which it wallpaper the the coloured
bathtubs do you know like the the pink
pink in the the beige and the green
whatever bathtubs and toilets and look
for them because you divorce you not had
a reef or bit in a long long time and
then go and see them did you when you
were growing up were you the area where
they had those sort of things
not really no it was your bathtub when
you idiot
I don't remember that far back I was the
spurt horny a like 82 so I don't
remember I didn't pay much attention to
what color the bathtub was I was more
interested in playing in the fields and
they I was in Scotland did where we used
to play outside
I didn't play in computer games so I was
more interested in riding motorbikes and
playing on quad bikes and so what about
saw the bloody bathtub so recognizing
the color of a bathtub is linked to
playing on computer games she played
computer games in the bath now no what I
mean is that I was more interested in
being outside than more Indian inside
anyway right back to the topic and so
look for the water properties you can
find and then get out that view them and
then do your numbers now with this
strategy you have to be super
conservative on numbers and what I mean
by that is do not get em get fixated on
an end value that is unrealistic and the
way to do that is look at what's been
sailing in the area very closely area so
I ideally on the same street on the
street along street that way and get
multiple opinions and what they think
the property will be worth when it's
done up and if need be speak to a
surveyor and say look I'm going to die
this is the property I want to get a
valuation in the end of it and and and
you'll have an idea so let's just say a
deal I'm buying at the minute it's fifty
three thousand pound refurb is estimated
between twelve and fifteen thousand the
end value should be about nineteen
ninety five thousand now in the street
there's been houses all for ninety eight
so we are saying ninety to ninety-five
now if we can refinance at ninety five
will pull most of our money out so we
just yeah do it that way now the bigger
the more expensive the house the bigger
cushion you're going to have generally
again I talked earlier about by refurb
deal we've found in London which is
worth 1.1 1.2 million when it's done up
but we can buy it for like between 700
and 715 so three things that you need to
know I suppose first of all is what you
can pay what you what you don't pay for
it now auctions are another good player
to find ya removals what you pay for it
now what the works are gonna cost ya and
then what it's gonna be done and the
thing is what's gonna the end value well
the in value is gonna be thing is the
difficult part is estimating the second
to what was intended before people tend
to do is they underestimate the refurb
yeah and they overestimate the estimate
the end value you had a situation didn't
you not with you but you knew somebody
that that massively cocked up the end
value and it meant the mentally left
loads of money in it than they was that
you was was talking to I was talking to
somebody recently Cathal was um and they
bought it was a buy refurb it was two
flats that they were buying and they're
just massively off when they were
showing me the numbers I'm like but what
made you think that they were worth that
I don't understand why you thought that
and he was at what I just thought they
would be and I met you but your thought
is irrelevant at this point nobody cares
about your opinion at this point we care
about the opinion of people that
actually meeting decisions and him he
ended up with about 15 20 thousand pound
left in the deal so for him it's not a
bio refurb defense it was just he bought
a bit of below market value house
converted into two flaps refinance there
in left loads of money in there and he
only put like 20 grand into in the first
place so it's like just you be super
conservative always underestimate the
end value so if you think it's me worth
150 what your figures out on 140 or 145
but just be very very conservative and
with build cost always be they add 10%
so if they come in and say it's if the
builders see it's gonna be 8 grand
budget 10 I know it's not ten percent
budget nine thousand six hundred or or
eight thousand eight hundred whatever
and just budget ten and a low ten for it
because trust me builders never stick to
budget I've never had one builder state
100 percent the budget they're always
over a little bit and so just yeah be
very conservative hmm so where's the
best places to find these deals I would
say obviously going to estate agents
directly mentions auctions yeah a good
place
and where else obviously you can look
online the cited websites online they're
designed for you know yeah so uh top
places for me right move right moves
your friend here
ninety percent probably start for still
in the UK are on right move its fact
okay Anne stairs got are saying that
right move is his best friend which i
think is sad but tracer movies my best
friend and so right move a zoo play as
well I was it right move that took you
to the theater was the right move again
for right a little right movie tried a
few right moves that night at area right
okay you've lost me again to it's gone
right moves goods they Gumtree for
directive n don't you get there's a lot
of my apartment apartments a lot of
property and Gumtree that's available
director vendor I found a Bangor on
gumtree in Lincoln and it was an old
house in sight believe or not inside the
house was an old train carriage I know
it sounds bizarre
so it was an N it was a courted end
cottage and they bought a train carriage
from like the 50's from London an old
would probably earlier a little wooden
train carriage and they put that on the
side of the house and they built over
and they used that as an extension and
that was their front room honestly it
was amazing inside but it was very
dilapidated very Rondon and I that was a
Gumtree lead I went to view it in that
the numbers just didn't stack on it very
well how much does the carriage wherfore
who knows but it been it being cut up
and all sorts to get it to fit wasn't
original so wouldn't be more that much
but yeah it was actually when I quite
and saved this house there was a train
carriage in now I'll see if I can find
football grass in vikarna land I'll give
them to Nick and you'll maybe drop them
in there I don't know I'm sure one of my
fallen somewhere but y'all see if I can
find only one of you phones
welcome personal anyway so by we
probably find ours infinite returns
fantastic strategy and notice your
favorite strategy is definitely my
favorite strategy I think everyone
should be doing it I think it's
phenomenal strategy on that no it's now
time for this
[Music]
so in the news this week Samuel has
helped Glenn Kirkham yep Ranko come from
black belt become become financially
free it was really obvious Lee we saw
this in it's been in a couple of
different newspapers yeah local
newspapers so we thought we'd include it
if anyone hasn't watched it it's been on
on the YouTube channel it's really
really interesting doc just over an hour
and 20 minutes long and it's a great
it's a great story as well because Glenn
obviously we met Glenn on he was one of
the he was editing the eviction and he
he was sort of seeing I remember him
saying to me like you know I'm watching
all these guys I really want to get into
it then he came along to a crash-course
spoke to Samuel said hey can you help me
take me and and he did he's obviously
very ill acclaimed story I don't know
what you guys thought about this but
like watching the documentary was
actually do you know it made me like a
little bit emotional watching when story
because like the fact that he's got this
tumor in his esophagus and the minute
it's benign but the speaking to Calais
and I'm sure he won't mind me sureness
like if the if he wants that cure if he
wants up taken out they can take it out
but the surgery is ridiculously invasive
and it's very very it's fraught with
risks and it basically means the
coroner's office away and connected to a
summer he's obviously a single anyone
well to sing yeah and it wound all sorts
and but he's an amazing guy and he's got
he's got young families got our partner
with him this really supportive and you
know what it couldn't have gone to our
more deserving guy and he's done
phenomenally well out of it so and he as
you saw from the video he's an action
taker he is a little bit it was a bit he
got the jitters
he did he got the jitters but that's
normal it's good for people to watch it
because number one anyway if you haven't
watched it go and check it out but it
basically goes through the steps half
you can financially free in a week if
you really really go for it it's not how
to it's this is how we're going to and
it's them out doing it so it's not this
is not just them
by the cameras in this they do it
they're actually out doing it live and
so Glenn does the Samuel obviously says
to him don't do this gonna do that but
Glenn's the one actually doing the work
actually negotiations and like you say
he gets cold feet doesn't wander the
deal so very very interesting dark
certainly if you're wanting to get into
property wanting to know many down deals
become finally free so dude I can't
remember the exact deals he got I know
he got I know you've got one hit gym or
he got a couple of service accommodation
apartments he's done a better deal
sawsan he's though is since the event
since their Vic the eviction
since the MFF challenge using what he's
learned he's actually gone on to secure
nine properties on a lease option
agreement from one landlord that's just
amazing and they're all new lease option
agreement so it's very very on doing it
it's just paralleled and this is like
you know so many people say that but
it's not possible and you can't do this
in a week come on guys how much proof do
you need
and it's like all these people you know
right they we see it that we see this
Lots yeah people that come to this event
constantly they come to the bake the
crash cross time and time again the same
people and the they just don't believe
that is possible and they don't believe
that they can do it but like Glen
thought that and now look um and he got
some meant when he got some help and
he's gone out and killed it and it just
proves that the strategy is what it
proves it all was yes there's going to
be problems
so yeah Glen's had a problem with it up
with our tenon or two but that's last
life that's that's business that's what
happens in the property industry we have
problems with tenants deal with um move
won't get better tenants or get new
tenants that is life and this video is
highlighted that it's not always glory
it's not always it's not always the best
Glen face that he had some issues that
you had to deal with in his head he had
some issues with the problems with the
properties yeah he dealt with it yeah he
did a great job but did a great job and
that's what successful people do
successful people they go in there and
they and they when they get faced of a
challenge or a struggle they plow on
through do you know what I get sick of
here and all these unsuccessful people
online mourning and bitching and trying
to blame somebody else for their lack of
success it does my head in
it's like take responsibility for you
and stuff dudes take responsibility man
up come on people do that because
they've got a god named someone but when
somebody love them someone so yeah
interestingly law like I've seen this
this a lot as well like people that are
be like for instance when I attended the
DfE two years ago there was some day at
the same DfE as me very very critical of
a very critical saying it wasn't useful
no value and I'm like we were at the
same DfE come on the same DfE so how can
one person attend that DfE go and do
i've done and also in the same room
there was three or four other people are
really killed it but one person seen on
earth rubbish
they've done nothing me and about four
phyla people from that same event I've
done phenomenally well
so how they've got the same information
same we were there in the same room how
can what a smaller I hope him a group of
people go and do really well but then
one person seen this rubbish well
they're just not in there in the right
place at the right time are they so it's
one of those one of those okay it's now
time for this okay so first question
this is from Stefano loved the podcast
great job lads thanks Devon a question
on a by refurbish refinance how many
times this happen where we do a
subjectivist amazing on a borrow photos
France can you get refinance on a
property before you let it out all the
lenders want to see income coming in on
the few on the first few months right
now the refinery finance from my
knowledge and from the ones I've done
can be achieved as soon as it works with
them commercial properties are often
done like that because then they want to
do a commercial valuation but it but
honor on a residential they'll just do a
bricks-and-mortar valuation well okay so
you will be you'll be fine step down for
that Stefano good morning good morning
or evening if you're watching this in
the evening yeah or afternoon if you're
watching it and you
when doing lease options and you were
going to take over the mortgage payments
to the mortgage lenders do any checks on
who is taking over the mortgage payment
for example so they do some background
checks if you're buying the property
yourself good credit score income etc we
are looking into getting compliance soon
and getting into sourcing and getting
lease options cheers guys that's from
Graham hickling Hickling cool right okay
so lease option agreement and you can
yeah your credit scored that don't come
into it you typically take over the
mortgage payments now not all lenders
will allow the mortgage payments to be
changed from they'll allow okay so my my
my lease options I'll tell you how I've
done that every single one of them the
vendors have not been happy with the
direct debit coming out of my bank to go
to the mortgage lender don't trust you
it's the untrustworthy look so the
reason being is available what if you
don't pay the mortgage and I'm like you
but what you don't pay the mortgage okay
so and they're a lot bored if you don't
think went all funny place my what we've
done in the end was I spoke to our
solicitor about Andy said Luke it's not
a problem you just pay them directly for
it and then every three months or every
six months whatever you decide just ask
them for a mortgage statement or proof
that the mortgages have been getting
paid and a lot of mortgage lenders will
not if you ring up and say hey my name's
James Smith I'm gonna be taking over the
mortgage the payments on the mortgage on
this property the Alain start asking the
questions why and technically they're
probably not allowed to I don't know the
legalities of this I would say they're
not allowed to do it from my experience
with working with in the finance finance
sector is you cannot have a direct debit
coming out of somebody else's bank for
some things in your name and because
then you could reclaim all that for
instance I used to work for a finite a
comic store finance and we had our
client bought some products in his name
but they changed to direct debit so it
was coming at the bank of somebody else
and that other person was not on the
account that person then split up but
then separated and
the girlfriend run up the final company
said look you've been taking 100 pound
at my account the last seven months I
didn't authorize that and it's it's not
even for a product I've got we have to
pay her that money back not me the
compound work for their to pay the money
back to her because they shouldn't have
done it so there's lots of laws
regarding direct debits and things out
so be very very careful about it speak
to the solicitor about it and worst case
if need be if you're if you're concerned
about paying direct to the vendor just
say up are a joint bank account with you
to that yourself and the the home owner
and that's one way to do it and all
that's been recommended to me in full by
solicitor or do it that way or just pins
all right I believe that that kind of
fit you credit rating it can affect your
credit rating if they've got bad credit
yeah so it may because obviously credit
rating comes in the bank own so that
that for me would be an absolute last
last straw last result okay so question
all right this is missing from Johnny
Peters hey cheeky boys hey Johnny hey
bro always loved the podcasts you do do
you think it would be a good idea to
offer si on a month-to-month basis
taking into consideration the money
invested into it initially to get a
return back first
I've seen their do this strategy in
America if the owner is happy they
continue with it more risky but
potentially could get more essays off
this what do you think so I'm assuming
he means do a month a month I like a
30-day rule and contract for when you
take the problem the problem with that
is but first two problems that come into
my head number one would be you might if
you if you spend money on furnishing in
whatever you do and then after a month
they're like alright thank you bye-bye
see ya
that's first problem and then the second
problem is I actually don't think they'd
be more interested in doing it know
things and landlords prefer to get along
the term so interesting I don't know I
mean it they might be more open to it in
the early stages if you look try it for
three months and if we like it we can
put it in there might there may be yeah
there
nervous so I don't know man I would I
would say it's not gonna work for the
exact same reasons that you said Lando's
want longevity and you want to make sure
your investments secure because if you
invest in it and then you only get 30
days me and then and lot of thing as
landlord says actually it's working very
well why don't I do it myself it's very
true very true there you go so good
Johnny if you try it please let us know
how it goes right last one
Nathaniel hang what is the prediction of
what house sale and rental prices will
do in London and the South East next
five to ten years considering the
government's focus on economic growth in
the north hashtag the northern
powerhouse
well we taught submit that's waiting
women right now a half price is in
London a set set to rise I think breaks
it's gonna come there's gonna be a
little dip there's gonna be a little a
few months or six months or even maybe a
year of scarcity and then it's gonna
just as rule of thumb it's there's
economic growth everywhere but
particularly in places like London and
then rule of thumb is every else follows
London so I'm sure I'm sure London will
go up and everywhere else will will fire
so yeah I think we what do I know
yeah what do we know on that bombshell
it's time to end we will see you next
week tune in at 7:00 p.m. on Saturday
evening this is very light like very
weird how how how you doing this dude do
I normally do this at the end you guys
let's back up a step back any wire okay
go on this bombshell
you